منظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من دواء قاتل
يعالج السعال الرئيس الاسرائيلي يحذر من
نهايه اسرائيل خلال سنوات وطفل بريطاني في
الرابع ينال عضويه جمعيه العباقره هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقلها لكم من قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم
بعد ما تسببت في وفاه المئات بثلاث دول
العام الماضي ضاعت منظمه الصحه العالميه
السلطات الصحيه الى اتخاذ اجراءات فوريه
ومتضافره لحمايه الاطفال من ادويه سعال
سامه المنظمه الصحه في بياننا اكثر من 300
طفل ومعجمهم دون سن الخامسه توفوا في
غامبيا واندونيسيا واوزباكستان خلال العام
20 22 بسبب مشاكل في الكلى الناتجه عن
استعمال ادويه تحتوي المواد سامه فيما
يحتوي دواء السعال المتاح دون وصفه طبيه
على مستويات عاليه من مواد اعتبارا
الكيميائيه سامه قد تكون قاتله حتى لو تم
تناولها بكميات صغيره
في تصريح غير مسبوق حضر الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق هيدروك من انهيار اسرائيل خلال
السنوات القليله المقبله مذكرا بدولتي
مملكه داوود والحجم نائم اللاتيني لم تصمد
لاكثر من ثمانين عاما هل سوفان في تصريحات
نقلتها صحيفه تايمز اوف از رويال ان غياب
الحوار يمسك اسرائيل من الداخل معتبرا ان
الوضع الداخلي على وشك الانفجار وذلك على
خلفيه ازمه سياسيه حاده خلفها اعلان حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو عن خطه لاصلاح القضاء
وصفتها المعارضه بالانقلاب فيما شاهدت تل
ابيب تظاهر ضخمه سبت الماضي ضد هذه الخطه
في احدث مشكله قانونيه لالم ماسكه رفعت
شركه عقاريه في سان فرانسيسكو الامريكيه
دعوه قضائيه على شركه تويتر وذلك للتخلف
الاخيره عن دفع ايجار المكاتبها الرئيسيه
لشهرين ديسمبر
وبحسب الدعوه تخلفت تويتر عن دفع اكثر من
ثلاثه مليون دولار ايجارا لشهر ديسمبر
الماضي ومبلغ تجاوز ثلاثه مليون دولار
ايضا ايجارا مستحقا لشهر يناير الجاري
كذلك تخلفت الشركه عن دفع ايجار مكاتبها
في كل من لندن واسيا ياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي يقوم فيه المالك الجديد لتويتر الى
الناس بحمله كبيره لتخفيض التكاليف عبر
الاستغناء عن الاف فيلم الموظفين
طفل بريطاني بعمر الرابعه بعضويه جمعيه من
سلمى التي لا يدخلها سوى الاشخاص الذين
يتمتعون بقدر عالم من الذكاء ليحقق بذلك
نجاح مبهرا ويثير تفاعل واسعا في مواقع
التواصل صحيفه ديل ميل اوضحت في تقرير لها
ان الطفل باستطاعته القراءه والعدل من
واحد الى 100 بسبع لغات سبت منها اجنبيه
بالنسبه اليه من بين هذا الموديل ويزيه
الفرنسيه الاسبانيه والالمانيه فيما نجح
الطفل في الاختبار المعرفي لنيل عضويه
الجمعيه بعد ما حصل على 139 نقطه من اصل
160 في انجاز ابهر والديه
في خبرنا الاخيره شاهدت مباراه مانفيكا
وسبورتنج لشبونه في بطوله كاس البرتغال
للسيدات سابقه تاريخيه في عالم كره القدم
وهي اشهار حكم المباراه بطاقه بلون ابيض
صحيفه بريطانيه اوضحت ان احنا اللاعبات
فقط على الارض بعد تعرضها لاصابات
طاقم الطبي من الفريقين الى ارض الملعب من
اجل تقديم العلاج لها مضيفه انه بعد
انتهاء الطاقه من مهمتهما ساره حكم اللقاء
الى اشهار البطاقه البيضاء وهو تصرفا يهدف
الى تشريع القيام الرياضيه والانسانيه في
لعبه كره القدم وفقا لما ذكرته الصحيفه
[موسيقى]